meet the people behind the titles on
booknotes
each week the authors of public policy
historical and political books introduce
their newest works and offer fresh
perspectives on key public affairs
issues of the day
this week our guest is neil postman
chairman of the department of
communications arts at new york
university he joins us to discuss his
book technopoly the surrender of culture
to technology
[Music]
neil postman author of technopoly
the surrender of culture to technology
what's your book all about
the
the tendency in
american culture
to turn over to technology
sovereignty command control
over all of our social institutions
in other words the book is about how
america has
developed a new religion as it were
and the religion is its faith
in
that human progress and technological
innovation are the same thing and that
paradise can be achieved
through greater and greater commitment
to technology
what is technology
well i have to define it in the book
rather broadly because not only do i
include machinery like television
and computers and all of that but also
techniques
i call them invisible technologies
because most people
don't think of them as a sort of
machinery but things like
statistics and polling
and
bureaucratic forms
any
systematic and repeatable technique that
tends to
cause people to
constrain their thinking about the world
we talked a number of years ago about
television
uh
what impact
is technology having on television and
what's what's the impact on the country
well
one of the reasons brian that i i felt i
did this book is that the the last time
we talked as you suggest uh was about a
book that was almost wholly devoted to
television
and when i started to think about that
issue i realized that you couldn't get a
an accurate
handle
on what we americans were all about by
focusing on one medium
that you had to see television as part
of a kind of
system
of
techniques and technologies that are
giving the shape to our culture for
instance
if one wants to think about what has
happened to public life in america
uh and
one has to think of course first about
television but also about cds
and also about um
all sorts of
well faxes and telephones and all of the
machinery that that takes people out of
public arenas
and
keeps them fixed in their homes
so that we have a kind of privatization
of american life and one here is people
say with some considerable enthusiasm
that in the future
putting television computers in the
telephone together
people will be able to shop at home
vote at home
do every express political preferences
in in many ways at home so that they
never have to go out in the street at
all and never have to meet their fellow
citizens in any context because
we'd have this ensemble
of technologies
that keep us private
away from
from citizens in fact i think
ross perot's idea of a town meeting
is a new kind of definition of town
meeting because it doesn't imply
co-presence
uh of people he wants to do it via
electronic media so that television and
as well as other technologies redefine
all sorts of things i mean television
has redefined as i think we talked about
last time
what we mean by a public debate
that
we used to use the lincoln douglas
debates as an example as kind of model
or metaphor of what we mean by uh
political debate
these debates would go on for hours
television has redefined it
so now the two or
possibly three candidates staying in
front of the television camera and each
one is given two minutes to respond to a
very difficult question
and the opponent is given 60 seconds to
reply
now we still call this a debate
uh but it's a redefinition of of that
term
and uh uh ross perot's suggestion that
we use television as a form of uh
a town meeting is another redefinition
of what we once met by town meeting so
that the one of the most interesting
things about technology
is that it redefines
our language it it gives us different
meanings
of older words and very often we're not
quite
as aware as we should be
of how that process is working
good or bad
well in this book i mostly emphasize the
bad part
i've done that in most of my books but i
oh i admit and
happily at the beginning of the book
that anyone who
[Music]
looks at technology as an either or
development that is either all good or
all bad um is making a mistake
that
all technological uh change is what i
call a faustian bargain
it gives you something but it also
taketh away something
uh now in america and this is one of the
reasons i thought i should write this
book
we tend to be extremely enthusiastic
about technology
about
what it's going to bring us
so that
almost any american
in considering
anything from
lasers to
to computers to television
can tell you for a half hour or more
what this new technology will do for us
but there are very few people who have
ever considered what a new technology
will undo
so i wrote my book from the point of
view of what it will undo
how it will
change and has changed
for the worse
some of our social institutions and
psychic habits
but
it's this doesn't mean that i uh i'm
unaware
of
the positive
possibilities of some of the new
technologies
religion
you talk a lot about religion what does
the new technology do to religion well i
i fear
that
our faith in technology
uh has weakened
uh a more traditional
sense of spirituality
that technology implies a kind of
rational
or i should say
an emphasis on the rational
because
technologies work that's see that's the
wonderful thing about them
airplanes do fly
and penicillin
i think tends to make people better
and the television does show you someone
in some far off place
so uh
technology works in in an unambiguous
way
uh in in the way that prayer for
instance or even
faith in god
doesn't always work
and i i don't think
all this began yesterday
in fact in the book i tried to
show
how beginning and really in the 17th
century
the
the faith
that people had in
a
benign design in the world
has weakened
and uh in our own century
seems to have been replaced
uh almost in a religious sense
by a faith in
progress
and progress through technology we will
reach heaven
uh if we can
produce bigger and better
machinery
and techniques in fact there are some
people who even believe we can solve
the problem of death through
technology i think it's called what is
called the cryogenics
uh so that even that
ultimate
problem that human beings have always
had to deal with and which are religious
uh systems had always confronted i mean
that was one of the most
significant parts of our religious
systems to help us confront the idea of
death
in a technopoly we say well you don't
have to
rely on faith
through science and technology
will be able to freeze you
until at some
future date
a solution is found to the disease
that is is killing you now so so don't
worry just have faith so
in in summary uh on your question i
would say that um
uh
the
faith and belief
in technological solutions
has largely replaced what we now might
think is an older more traditional
uh notion of spirituality and faith in
some transcendent
design
you made a point early in the book about
how martin luther got started
with the ability to
proselytize or to sell his
point of view through the printed word
yes well luther of course was um
uh
one that was absolutely prescient
on the impact of the uh the printing
press although in a letter he wrote to
the pope after he had posted his theses
on the church door
he
i think feigned
surprise
that
his message his his complaints against
the church had been translated into
vernacular languages and spread so
quickly all over europe through the
printing press
he thought he as he said in his letter
he had written these objections in the
academic language and
he didn't think
ordinary people would have access to it
but he didn't know
the power
of the printing press he understood it
better than almost anyone of his time
and was not reluctant to credit
the printing press
with the advancement of his ideas and of
the
the reformation
so um
i i like to write about luther just from
that point of view
because um
uh he understood uh
say better than people like copernicus
and later of course galileo
what the printing press would mean
although galileo was i should i
shouldn't underestimate him because he
was also one
who
made use
of the printing press he had one
available to him for
propaganda purposes
in particular spreading the idea that he
had invented the telescope which in fact
he had not done
but
the the reason i brought up uh these
matters in the book about luther and
some of the others was uh to show
how new technologies
transform
uh everything about a culture
i mean the there's a tendency of people
to think
that new technology is additive
and i think it's new technologies are
ecological and what i mean is that if
you
put the printing press into europe
in the
mid 15th century
you don't have 50 years later europe
plus
the printing press you have a new europe
because everything gets changed the
political system the religious system
and so on if you put television
into america in in 1946
by 1960
you don't have america just plus
television
but a new kind of america so that our
social
relations are altered and our attitudes
toward childhood are altered and our
political system
uh is altered and we get
new meanings of old words and so on so
uh that's not something that's new in
culture that's why i discussed luther in
the book that this happens whenever you
get new technologies but the difference
now
is that when luther lived
uh
the the printing press was changing
europe he understood that
but then
western culture
had about
300 years
to adapt itself
to the printing press
so we developed new forms of economic
life
new
political ideas new notions about
education all organized around the
printing press but in our own time our
situation is much more difficult to cope
with because almost
daily it seems
new technologies
come on the scene and our social
institutions don't have time
to assimilate them and reorganize
themselves
to
accommodate the demands of the
technology as soon as soon as you start
to do that
some new technology comes to make that
one obsolete so everyone is in quite a
state of confusion but the reason i call
america the first technopoly is that
uh more than any other culture that i
can think of
we have committed ourselves
to technology our destiny now is
tied up
with technology
by the way the germans and the japanese
and the even the koreans would dearly
love to become technopolis
and are moving very
rapidly in the direction of american
culture
we are taping this during the democratic
convention
we're surrounded by technology
but just as important we're very close
to where you live
where do you work and what do you do
every day
well i'm i'm a professor at new york
university and
chair of a department called the
department of culture and communication
and
what one of the things i do every day is
is receive faxes
and and send them
and just a as a little side note brian
at the moment i noticed that most people
who send faxes
still think of them as telegrams
they don't
so some people realize that you can
write a whole
long letter in the facts
but one does get faxes that say see you
thursday stop
hope you'll be there and so on uh faxes
i think may
help to restore
uh the skill of letter writing in the
years ahead but mostly what we do in our
academic way is to try to study these
processes that we've been talking about
to try to raise the questions of what's
to become of us
um
if we
lose a sense of
a spirituality
if we
uh devote all of our resources
and our psychic energies
to uh making uh bigger and better
machinery and designing better
techniques
will we become
less human in some sort of traditional
way of defining that
i notice that of course people will be
seeing this after the
democratic convention but many people
are surprised
that candidate clinton
chose
albert gore as a
vice president
and
people said well what about regional
politics because their states are
they're from the same region and i think
the states are contiguous
um well what what does regional politics
mean in the in the age of television
uh does it make any sense to talk about
the idea of
making sure you have someone from
the north or from the far west if you're
from the south and
and the east i'm not i i mean i think
that's just one of these ideas that
that has no relevance in an age of
of television who owns new york
university
well new york university is the largest
private
university in america
it has about
42 000 students i think about four
thousand
faculty
it began in 1831
so it's one of our older
institutions
and
until recently i'd say about 20 years
ago
it largely served the new york city
community
and i'd say
80 percent of the accountants and
lawyers and doctors and dentists
in new york at least of my generation
had some connection with with nyu within
the past
25 years i'd say it's become a great
international
university a great research uh
institution
and so
it's not really uh owned
by anyone although it's as i speak the
chairman of our board of directors is mr
lawrence tisch who is also has the
controlling
stock of cbs
so uh
i mean one might wish to say if one were
in a nasty mood that cbs
has owns nyu but it's not really it's
not really that that way
and nyu is doing
very nicely i mean compared to
some of the other big eastern and
private universities like colombia and
yale about whom your audience perhaps
has heard
uh are plagued with financial
difficulties how big is your department
we have 24
full-time professors
and
i'd say
700 or 800 students
a new york university i should add has
many
departments of communication
including its famous tisch school of the
arts which produces all the young
and now famous
movie directors
but uh uh in uh we have discovered
that uh the field of communication
is
a fast-growing one
and we'll continue to do it
to to grow
it's pretty obvious to many young people
that
the best way or among the best ways
to study any society
is to study
its communication systems
its mesh message systems
that in fact you could almost define a
culture
by merely describing
what are its dominant modes
of communicating with itself not only
human to human but now human to machine
machine to human machine to machine
and so on so there's a tremendous
interest in studying the sub this
subject from an historical point of view
as well as uh ethical and philosophical
and so on how long have you been at the
new york university i've been there
32 years
where'd you grow up
i i grew up i grew up in brooklyn new
york
uh and
just to the record was a
devoted brooklyn dodger fan
which probably explains some of my
prejudices against los angeles which are
really quite irrational but
if you want to understand
my background
i'll tell you about
i think it was pete hamill the uh
new york city columnist who once was
asked who were the three
most evil people
in this century and he said adolf hitler
joseph stalin and walter o'malley
your audience may not know
but uh who o'malley was but he uh he was
the owner of the dodgers who moved them
to los angeles but i grew up uh
in brooklyn and went and went to school
um here
so um where
uh
you mean college well i i actually i
started at the ccny many many years ago
which is city college um but then went
on to the state university of new york
and in the western part of the state in
fredonia and
which is a notorious place because in
one of the marx brothers movies there's
a place called fredonia
but then i went off of my graduate work
to columbia and your degrees in what
well i started out as an english teacher
and
my first
my graduate work was largely in
linguistics and my first job
was at san francisco state
college
as a
teaching linguistics
13 books
or is this the 14th well
actually it's 20 if you count if you
count the textbooks but we'll set it for
five
books which one of those 13 at least the
consumer books ha
which one sold the most
a book that i wrote with uh
an old friend named charles weingarten
called teaching as a subversive activity
that was a book
published in 1969
uh it was about education and it came
during the um
those very hectic and uh exciting
school reform days
where many people were writing books
about that subject and i think it sold
about
about half a million copies
and so
my name first
became
familiar with readers
in the field of education through that
book but obviously in more recent years
uh the book amusing ourselves to death
which
i think has probably sold about 200 000
copies now and
unlike the other book has been extremely
uh
uh
well selling in europe
uh especially in scandinavia and germany
and
very often i'm asked when i'm in europe
if i can explain
why a book like amusing ourselves to
death and another one called the
disappearance of childhood
uh are popular in europe
and so i've given it some thought
and the best i can come up with
is something like this
that um
the europeans and speaking now of
western europe
are about 10
years
behind us
in
uh in its relationship to technology
the germans and the swedes and the danes
and the
belgians
they look across the atlantic
and they see
some of the
harmful effects
of technology as has happened here in
america
and so they're more wary about
technological change than americans are
americans
have always had
a sort of lust for the new
that's a quote from de tocqueville
because he he knew that about us
in the mid-19th century we've had a lust
for the new so we accepted technology
more readily than other people
and we have had to suffer some of the
consequences of that so the europeans
look at this
and they ask themselves
this question which is a good question
is it possible
for us
to
maximize
the benefits of new technologies
while minimizing some of the negative
consequences
can we through education or political
action or social policy
inhibit
technology
from destroying the that which we wish
to preserve that's a good question
and i don't know the answer to it and
they don't know the answer to it but
they're asking it
and sometimes i think i like to
put this sort of
hypothetical
issue to people suppose it were
1906
and we knew what we know now about the
automobile the combustion engine and we
were able to have a conversation about
it
a national conversation and someone
listed for us all of the benefits
of the automobile which are many and
then all of the deficits including that
it would poison our air and choke our
cities and
uh create the suburbs
some people would put on that side but i
might put on this side
and um uh and then we said well let's
discuss this and then we'll have a
plebiscite
we now know what it will do and we know
what it will undo
well i think most americans would say
well let's go ahead with it anyway
but someone was bound to say
let's go ahead with it but is there
anything we could do
to reduce this list over here to
minimize the negative consequences well
in 1906 if we had had such a
conversation
there even with limited knowledge there
probably were things
we could have done
to
reduce
the negative
items on the list
when television came along
it would have been in theory possible to
have the same conversation
what are the benefits what are the
deficits
let's talk about it
and then let's see is there anything we
can plan to do
that would minimize the uh
the deficits
well we didn't have such a conversation
and with the computers now we're not
having such a conversation
all we hear is
what they will do for us we don't hear
what they will undo so one of the
purposes of a book like this was to see
if it's possible to start such a
to start such a conversation
and make us more sophisticated in our
approach to
[Music]
new technologies and for that matter old
technologies
how's it going
the book yep
well it's in its fourth printing and uh
now what does that mean well
uh you mean how many copies
my guess is at this point probably about
uh 50 000 copies it's of course
available only in hardback and
we'll probably do a lot better than that
when it's in the paperback but in
addition to that
it's being uh adopted in many college
classrooms which happened incidentally
with amusing ourselves to death
uh uh and i'm i'm
very happy about that because
i think the younger people
are going to have to think more
seriously
about technology than any other group
in the country so i'm
happy that
it's being used in universities you
still teach
i do i won't be teaching in the fall
because i'm an administrator
uh at least part of the time
and that's a new experience for me brian
because
for 30 years i was
as i still am a professor but one who
had scrupulously avoided having anything
to do
with
administration
so i i don't have as much time as uh to
devote to teaching as i once did but i
still do teach and we'll be teaching in
the spring
got to ask you what's happening to you
because
some of your followers
will be disappointed to learn that you
just got cable television
you're going to be an administrator and
have cable television in your home
what's happening
i guess moral rot is setting in front
the
pod of course the cable
i got cable during the
persian
war with gulf war
because cnn
was what one had to watch to know what
was going on
but i've maintained it because
[Music]
what is on
traditional broadcast television i find
now mostly unwatchable
so that
i like uh
i like old movies especially those
made in the 1930s and 40s and there are
a couple of stations that do that and of
course
c span is
now
essential
especially
this program which is one of the reasons
i was so happy when you called
as an observer this is not why you're
here but as an observer it'd be
interesting to know what you see
on television now you have cable
like for instance this this network is
much different pace much slower pace
we don't have nielsen numbers we know
that the audience isn't huge
you go over to another more commercial
operation and it's a much bigger
audience and all that what
um what do you think the impact of the
different channels
is having well is that something i i've
had occasion to think about
quite a bit
because
when i wrote amusing ourselves to death
i would have thought
that any station that had talking heads
on it for any length of time was
absolutely doomed
that people liked to watch television
not really
to listen to it much but watch it and
what they liked to watch
were dynamic exotic
fast-changing imagery
which the networks and other commercial
broadcast stations are providing and
incidentally as we speak most cable
stations still provide
but i have
had to
modify
that idea somewhat
because i have
noticed
that there are
stations
c-span
for example
but that's not the only one
that
is
quite where they're quieter
the pace is slower there you don't have
a new visual image to process every 3.5
seconds
and people
watch
and apparently listen
and uh and then go back and watch again
so i'm very encouraged
by that it may be that um
that there are limits to how much the
human psyche
can
take
of this fast-moving imagery that has
been a characteristic of american
television for many years and
the nielsen people tell us that
television is on about
close to eight hours a day
in the average american household
so maybe there are limits
to how much imagery people can process
and maybe there is the television itself
created a need in people
for more quiet conversation
and
for
human faces that can actually be
perused and and uh uh
studied and
listened to in your book you dedicated
uh for faye and manny who are faye and
manny faye and manny
are my deceased
mother-in-law and father-in-law
two
wonderful people
in fact
in a previous book
i wrote called conscientious objections
which was a group of essays
i had occasion to write about my
father-in-law
manny who spent all his life not far
from here on seventh avenue as a a dress
cutter but who was a man of uh exquisite
taste
and
[Music]
reason
there were many people like that in his
generation
and so uh and of course my my
mother-in-law was uh
who died
four years ago
uh was a very gentle and uh
uh
intelligent woman and so i felt i wanted
to do this
madonna
and mozart madonna who who's that
you write about madonna you write about
mozart beethoven and you suggest that
madonna shouldn't be the only answer for
people what do you mean by
that well in uh
there is uh toward the end of this book
i have a um
i felt i had to address the question of
what well what should we do about all
this
uh now you know social critics are
usually not very good at answering that
question their strong point is
telling you the bad news but i did try
to say something uh positive
and i felt that the answer might be in
in education
and the idea there is
that madonna
and bruce springsteen
and
hollywood and cbs and all of that
is not going to go away
our young people will have continuous
access to them
i suggest therefore
that in their schooling
there should be an emphasis on more
traditional
forms of expression art and literature
and otherwise
not
to
blacken
the reputation of the popular arts
but just to make sure
that the young
have
access to
different forms
of
understanding the world
and perhaps in that way
there could be some sort of synthesis in
their education that is this the sort of
person
madonna and bruce springsteen wants our
young to be
that's okay
but there's also the sort of person that
mozart
and uh
and dickens
wanted people to be
so i think i young have to have
available to them both
world views
uh
that's so i'm i'm not
who could rule out madonna for anything
i mean time warner if i'm not mistaken
just signed a 60 million dollar
deal with madonna so she's going to be
with us in every imaginable form that's
all right
no one wants to stop that but i think
the education of the young
or to pretend as if madonna is not there
in the in the classroom because as soon
as the children leave the classroom
madonna will be available to them while
they're in the classroom someone else
should be available
let me ask you
why do you think
as you know
mozart is a very popular among a small
percentage
population i mean very popular why
doesn't mozart appeal to the younger
people or or the majority of people what
is the difference
first of all i'm not i i'm not sure that
mozart wouldn't appeal
why doesn't he
well what i mean is that in part
he is
not
heard as enough
in part because his music is more
complex than bruce springsteen so that
one has to go to mozart with a prepared
imagination and a prepared mind
but also brian because
mozart's music
box music handles music
uh
is about it is it it's a different world
view i mean to listen to that music
is to believe that there is order in the
world
that there's a design in the world
uh that god's in this heaven
and maybe not all's right with the world
but that there is a
pattern um
it's it that's it's it's refined and
organized one can't help sense that to
listen to rock music
i think the world view is that there is
no order
and i think for a lot of young people
this is the world they know and
therefore the rock music
is consonant with their outlook but i
would argue this is all the more reason
why the young
in school
should be presented
with forms of expression
that
presume
that there is an ordered world and that
it has some meaning
that it's not all happenstance and
arbitrary
uh
now that i realize as a somewhat
religious
idea in itself certainly a transcendent
sort of idea
but uh but it's not especially sectarian
people did believe in in the medieval
world and and even into
to mozart's time and in the early days
of
of our own republic
that uh there was order in the universe
and that everything was not just a
matter of um
this and then this and then this and
then this and
there was no way to anticipate anything
when you're teaching uh your favorite
subject what is it
well these days it's it's the history of
technology but not just the description
of the machinery but the social effects
of new technology and in the book i make
these distinction among three kinds of
cultures tool using
technocracies and technopolies and i i
want students to know and get much
satisfaction out of their reading about
it and talking about it that
not all people believed technology uber
alice
that there were people and and still are
people in the world
who have uh organized
their minds and their social values
on some other set of beliefs
than
uh their redeeming
quality of technology what's a tool
using society today you said there were
very few well i think what what most
people would call third world countries
would be uh
roughly what we might mean by a tool
using
culture that is people whose
symbolic world their politics their
religion their education
are not commanded and dominated by
technology they have tools they invent
tools
but they always invent their tools to
solve
problems in the physical world
but they do not let the tools
control
their social and symbolic lives has a
study ever been done
uh take the technology that we live in
and take a tool using society that still
exists there has a study ever been done
about who's really up here in the head
happier
well i don't i don't know i i i what do
you think you know it's a good question
i uh a an anthropologist uh marvin
harris wrote a book some years ago in
which he uh was talking about how much
time
uh
men had to spend
getting food in a hunter gatherer
society and figured that figured it out
somehow that the average
you know joe loincloth
was probably spending about two hours a
day basically making a living
and then compared it
to someone today who's who has to spend
10 and 12 hours a day making a living if
if he can get a job at all
i don't think a study would help us
brian i i because it's a question of
values now i
i do say in the book because
uh in spite of what some reviewers have
said i'm i'm not an um
romantic completely
that
machinery
was the best hope
for
the
most of the people who lived in the
world
before the 18th century most people were
peasants
and
life was hard nasty brutus short as
the saying goes
so there's no doubt that machinery
especially in the age that i call a
technocracy
made life better
according to values that i think most of
us would accept people lived longer
through uh
they lived cleaner
they had more time for
a recreation and so on what's uh but can
i ask you
about technocracy what would be you have
the tool using and then we're a
technopoly what's a technocracy
technocracy is a culture in which you
have
a
serious
technology
competing
with
a more traditional
social and symbolic world japan
well
yes right the america was a good uh
example of this in the 19th century the
two world views the technological
and what you might call the humanistic
although that loads the case but the
traditional view of religion and
education and politics and so on those
two
[Music]
worlds rub against each other but
technology is not yet strong enough
to make the traditional world irrelevant
or invisible
we go over into technopoly
when the technological world overwhelms
the traditional world
as you know the show talks always about
books and i see a lot of different books
one of the more recent ones a couple of
them one of them was the truman book by
david mccullough it is huge it's a
thousand pages it sells for thirty
dollars
this book here sells for twenty one
dollars
it may have well let's see a couple
hundred pages in it
most of your books that i've seen have a
couple hundred pages in it right what's
the strategy well the straight is simple
i want people to read the book
and uh
uh uh without talking about the uh the
book about truman uh
in particular uh i think most books are
much too long and and that uh
uh authors uh of course uh some authors
write such
long books because they want to document
something they want this on the record
but i'm more interested in
readers
and so um
my books as you say tend to run about
200 pages i think i can say
what i have to say in 200 pages and i
think most writers of at least
non-fiction or social criticism whatever
you would call it can't pretty much say
what they have to say in 200 pages now
what did you say in this book that
almost everybody quotes back to you
the reviewers the people that read it
they say hey professor i read your book
and you said
uh
most of them concentrate on
what i have to say about social science
which is uh
i don't say much that's very good i
think it's what is social science well i
first of all i don't think it exists i
mean that's i don't think that sociology
psychology uh and anthropology are
sciences and i try to make a distinction
between science and those activities and
uh
in fact i even think brian economics
really is a branch of moral theology and
and should be taught more
in in
divinity schools than than in
universities um but uh
uh it does disturb me that so many
people have such faith
in
these subjects that are called social
science and go to experts
to find out how to raise children and
how to fall in love and how to make
friends
as if they believe
that because these subjects are sciences
in quotes here
that they are getting
verifiable
indisputable truths about the world so
that i i use social science as an
example of really a
technique this part of the machinery of
technopoly and most people who have read
the book including reviewers
seem to want to talk about that part of
the book more than any other
one of the things you suggest that ought
to be done is that when everything is
taught
it ought to be the history of it ought
to be taught along with it
whether that you know anything i assume
even economics where it comes from why
why well because if you don't teach the
history of what we once knew about
biology or
or economics or even mathematics
then
learning can become
or information becomes
a kind of consumer product
that facts become
you sort of
like something you're selling
but
i think
what we want here is for the young to
understand that what we think we know at
any given time
first of all is a product of what we
thought we once thought we knew it comes
from some place
and
that in the future
it will itself change
so the idea is for
a teacher to try to show the young
that learning is
an historical process
and that anything that we think we know
now
will probably be modified in the past
history is wonderfully good for this it
suggests the future we might in the
future i'm sorry and history is uh
is almost the best consciousness
raising subject
that we that we have available to us are
you going to write another book soon
are you doing it right now
i did it already
already written in the other one
it'll be out in september i wrote it
with a
friend and former student named steve
powers who is a journalist a tv
journalist it's called how to watch tv
news
uh it's a different kind of book from
this uh because it's uh it will only be
out in paper
and it's for a mass market i've always
wanted to write a book that people could
buy in supermarkets
and in drug stores but one that would be
about something that immediately
attracts their interest i mean the sense
that oh yes
i really should know about this because
i spend an awful lot of time watching tv
news and maybe these guys know something
about it that would uh would help me so
that'll be out in september i think want
to give us a hint as to what one
or two major suggestions you make in the
book
well
in a in uh
it is hard to do and that quickly but uh
people do have to know something
about the economic basis of news
because if you if you
turn on a new show or if you're a
regular watcher of some particular new
show and you know nothing about
how this is paid for
and who makes the money and where it
comes from then you are really quite
disarmed so we do spend a little time in
the book
describing to people
uh
what
what kind of uh money situation is
involved with new shows i think it's
also uh
it's it would be impossible and the best
the best tv news people have said this
over and over again i mean people like
cronkite
and dane rather and
the rest of them it'd be impossible to
have any uh make any sense out of the
world if you can find your knowledge of
the world to tv news
that you would have to do an awful lot
of reading
in order to make sense out of
what you're seeing on television news
also and maybe finally on this that i do
think people have to understand
why decisions are made on tv news shows
as to what
people will see
and in what order
because this is not done in a in a
haphazard way there is a
psychologic
involved in deciding
what people will see first
what they'll see next what they'll see
after that and what they won't see at
all the title of that book is going to
be how to watch tv news and it's going
to sell for
oh it's not going to be expensive
probably i i don't really know but
probably about five dollars and in paper
paperback yes
this is what the the one of his
books
in the market at this moment looks like
it's called technopoly and our guest is
neil postman
thank you very much for joining us thank
you brian
this place
you